we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to the voicemail that came in
early this morning
hi David I just wanted to know what your
thoughts on Tingler is it is like if you
believe if it's a good thing or a bad
thing whether or not it helped students
or hurts them yeah just wanted to listen
opinion thank you I don't think that
tinder which is a dating app is
objectively good or bad you always will
hear people who take very black and
white positions like for example meeting
over the Internet is simply not as good
as meeting people in person for this
reason or for that reason I don't buy
into that I think tinder is absolutely
fine I think one of the bigger upsides
of tinder is that it does allow for
people who might get very anxious or
uncomfortable in sort of initial
conversations with somebody you've just
met to interact with them via writing
via text before you actually meet them
in person and I think that might make it
so that people who who otherwise
wouldn't really be meeting anybody can
meet people I think that the the sort of
downside is that when you do the sort of
window shopping thing and you're making
a like a split-second decision mostly
based on someone's appearance about
whether you're interested in getting to
know them
there are probably good connections and
good relationships that never happen
because you're swiping no rather than
yes but big picture I don't think that
there's any big societal risk to tinder
I'm not on it myself but I I don't I'm
not an anti tinder person whatsoever if
you have like a good strong anti tinder
case to make then get in touch and let
me know we've got a great bonus show for
you today access the bonus show by being
a member sign up at WWE at medCom
or by becoming a patron for at least
five bucks a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I will speak to you on
the bonus show